hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the try not to smile
challenge I've got a collection of
videos I've got no soul and I'm going to
see if I cannot smile to these happy
delightful videos with which anybody
with a modicum of decency would smile
but not me cuz I've got no decency
whatsoever oh I thought he was gonna
crash
[Music]
I'd like it makes it easier to not smile
if you think that she's just completely
completely oh no mmm that's fine that's
nothing and nothing we just fake
laughing countess I don't think fake
laughing counts as smiling I think it's
a if it's mocking it doesn't count yeah
you stupid piece of [ __ ] this one's
called couple accidentally proposes to
each other at the same time
[Music]
well the only answers that you both have
to kneel if you're gonna do it do it
right
not good opposite of good hmm
I love the peanut gallery in the back he
had a ring for her all the so dies
not nice not happy angry when I see this
just pisses me off
now that one was called son reunites
with dad at airport after week-long
holiday not happy not happy why did that
dad abandon his son for a week on a
holiday just show mean all right this
one is called that baby learned it to
waves
yeah that's not you
that's not cute that's not the cutest
thing I've ever seen look at who who let
this baby just run around waving at
people you know that video of the bear
load wave you know that video of the
bear that would wave when it get waved
at that's what this reminds me of so I
just expect that baby to jump at their
jugulars and Maul him to death any
minute now
[Music]
thank you very cute aha very cute
yukkuri
[Music]
[Applause]
my dad when he leaves for work on first
not shoot just not sweet that's not a
wholesome that's not neat that's fine
there's nothing nice
there's nothing neat there's nothing
cute
nothing smile worthy about that at all
it's just a kid who's forgetful very sad
gee
this isn't a try not to cry that's not
what this is that's not what this is
just not what this is I'm just trying to
bring the mood down Oh God make a kid's
life happen to be an organ donor nah
no assisted dump dog for all I know that
dog might not have any legs this is a
head now I'm sad apparently this one is
mr. Dwayne the rock Johnson were
surprises a fan
I'd be like hugging a mountain god I'd
be intimidated by his height wonder what
his pits smell like there's probably
just looking for the bathroom and walked
in that way hey you all right this one's
called a deaf man finds out he's gonna
be a dad
[Music]
look how devastated he is at this news
he's so sad all his money down the drain
sighs life goals and ambitions Oh God
washed away he was destroyed no no this
is Todd Todd is the best popper Todd
sighs owner almost get bitten by a snake
and intervened no Todd
Oh God my camera uh 27 out of ten would
give all the pets
Todd is making a speedy recovery well
wishes for Todd Todd
who the [ __ ] is calling mom hi mom
recording a video at the moment I'm
doing a try not to smile look at this
look at this picture look at this
picture that's okay here's the story
this is Todd
Todd is the best popper Todd saw his
OMERS owner almost get bitten by a snake
and intervened he's making a speedy
recovery but this is his face after the
snake bite so he saved his owner from a
snake yeah no it's not sweet definitely
wouldn't make me smile because the
videos try not to smile it's not cute
it's a horrible horrible wound and you
shouldn't smile looking at it not that
brave not smile worthy all right anyway
I'll be I'll be there in just a few
minutes we got steady Korean oh I'll be
there and uh give me give me ten minutes
all right ten minutes okay that's unfair
see that's unfair that's not that that
that's unfair this one says heat index
was a hundred and tens we offered a cold
drink he went for a full body soak
instead no your water supply is tainted
fine this one's called the exact moment
when she finds out that heard adoption
went through
I'll hate inside my soul there you go
see tell us to try not to smile
challenge and I'm pretty sure if you
analyze the frames real close on my face
you'll find that I didn't smile at all
ever
and so therefore I won right and this is
it a smile look at my beautiful smile
thank you everybody so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed this hope you didn't
smile either because there was nothing
to smile about in any of those videos or
clips or gifts or whatever they were so
thank you everybody so much and good
news we're coming to Australia we're
going on tour in November which is two
months away from now so if you haven't
seen already check out toward markiplier
comm check out the tickets for yourself
also if you want to help support the
channel hit that join button see all the
cool memberships that you get for doing
so thank you all so much for watching
and as always I'll see you in the next
video bye bye